i've got a very special talk at the
table this morning only on cbs this
morning oprah sent this to us yesterday
she's revealing her new and highly
anticipated book club selection
good morning cbs this morning team hey
gail
i chose deacon king kong by james
mcbride as my next
book club selection long before the
events of
these past weeks during which our
collective hearts are being broken again
and again by the
images of violence against black people
in 2015 president obama awarded james
mcbride
the national humanities medal for
humanizing the complexities of
discussing
race in america that citation went on to
read through writings about his own
uniquely american story
and his works of fiction informed by our
shared story
his moving stories of love display the
character of the american family
well in a moment when our country roils
with righteous anger and grief
deacon king kong reminds us that when we
come together as a community
in compassion and empathy love triumphs
i am praying for justice and for love to
triumph in our country right now
and in naming deacon king kong my latest
oprah's book club selection
i'm hoping that readers will find in it
what i did some beauty
some sorrow some joy resilience and most
of all humanity and the understanding
that
while we struggle with pain and trauma
we can find
shelter in one another just as the
characters in the cause
housing project in mcbride's brooklyn do
thank you oprah nicely done oprah's
standing in her yard did you hear how
loud the birds are in california they
seem happy there
new york times best-selling author james
mcbride hello
james mcdrive james mcbride joins us
from his home in new jersey
james mcbride i have to tell you this i
remember when oprah was reading this
book
and halfway through she said i think
i've got i think i've got by the time
she was done she goes no question this
is it
and talk about the timing because here
we are in 2020
where people are protesting about race
relations in this country
you were writing about this very thing
in 1969
so i'm thinking what message does it
send to you at this moment
the timing of it all well i mean uh it
just shows that we
we still have um a little bit of you
know distance to cover but
that some of these problems are not new
and and uh it's really depends on how
you look at things
you know in terms of addressing them
they're complicated problems but
um they require uh you know complicated
and
and humane answers
you've got an interesting there are many
interesting dynamics in relationships in
the book but one of them is about a
pastor's wife
who has a friendship with a white police
officer sister g and she says this
you all don't watch out for us y'all
watch over us
how did you how did you approach your
portrayal of police officers during this
time
and listen this book was written way
before what we're going through now but
as you said
this is not a new new issue
well i mean you know like like any
african
like many black person i've had my
issues with the police but on the other
hand you know i have
family members who are police officers
and and i know that most cops don't go
to bed
you know they're not they're not
thinking of racism when they go to bed
they
probably worry about their wife sleeping
with the gardener or something so i
didn't really
um i wanted to humanize a part of the
world that most of us never see
and that included the people in the
projects as well as the officers
who uh who guard them that particular
character you're talking about
happens to fall in love with with sister
i don't want to give the book away but
sister g and that officer
um they end up they end up falling in
love which is you know
it happens in this world and um my job
as a writer is to show that kind of
thing to people because that's
that's really that's what really lasts
the it's the love that counts it's the
love that lasts and it's the love that
brings the joy and the humor uh
to to books into storytelling
i want to talk about the humor for just
a second because there's a lot of
there are a lot of issues to navigate in
this book but the thing that made me
laugh
out loud several times was your name
choices james
so it focuses on deacon sport coat whose
real name by the way is cuffy lampkin
he has a son named pudgy fingers he has
a friend named hot sausage
there's a funeral director named morris
hurley gurley there's a sweet corn
cousin who's fighting with her cousin
over the affections of puddin
and we can't forget light bulb so i'm
wondering i'm wondering about
what went into how you decided to name
your characters were you cracking up as
you were writing them too
oh i love i love naming these people
some of these names i've heard and used
and i knew some i knew a light bulb
i mean i knew i you know a lot of these
people these names are names that
people actually knew i mean a lot of us
have
you know we have crazy names in our
families and if you look at the world
as your family as i try to um
the nicknames that we give each other
are are
there pieces of love that we exchange
with one another
so yeah so it centers around the church
deacon whose sport code and all that's
going on in his life in this
boston housing project as you mentioned
you know some of these characters
ultimately what do you want us all to
take out of the book because there are
many story lines that are going through
it's about a drug dealer it's about
baseball it's about love it's about
betrayal
it it all weaves together in the end
what do you want our takeaway to be well
you know as we sit here today
i want people to know that we have a lot
more in common than we are different
all of us have a sport code in this book
the sport code is a guy who pulls out a
gun and shoots the worst drug deal on
the housing projects and
and the ensuing chaos that happens as a
result of that shooting
is often comically played out but the
fact is we we all
are pretty much the same we all have a
sport caller we all have some kind of
crazy uncle who
you know who shows up at christmas and
takes his teeth out or an aunt who has
50 cats that does something wild
and this is it gives us a chance to
forgive ourselves you know and
and we have to understand we are a
dysfunctional
but loving family um and that helps that
helps get me out of bed every morning
yeah me too me too because i so believe
and sport coat
who shot the drug dealer who we used to
coach in baseball
and part of the mystery was why did he
do that i love how you tied it all
together we thank you james mcbride
i'm curious what did you think when
oprah called you and said hey you're my
choice what did you think
oh man i mean i used to tell my brother
i said i never win nothing
no i can't say that you know it was a
great moment i i wish everyone could
experience
that feeling i recognized her voice
right away by the way
even though you know so let it be known
i knew who i was talking
i knew who it was okay all right
because a lot of people go this ain't
really you this ain't really you oprah
thank you james mcbride
congratulations dinkin deacon rather
king kong
there's a there's a story about king
kong that that too is on sale now
wherever you like to read your books and
you can read an excerpt of oprah's new
book club selection on
cbsthismorning.com